go on google everybody and just google
matthew mcconaughey
in wolf of wall street and watch that
[ __ ] scene and tell me you're not
[ __ ] mesmerized when he's teaching
leonardo dicaprio
about how to survive on wall street it's
the greatest thing ever was that
something off the top of your head or
was it scripted like that
what i put in this movie was about three
times
longer than what was scripted it was a
really well i remember this i
call these launch pad lines with
wooderson and days confused
there's three lines i work for three
weeks based off of one line that was
written
and it was a line that wooderson had she
said hey that's what i love about those
high school girls i get older but they
stay the same age
well i read that one and i was like who
the [ __ ] is that
yeah on this guy
you're referring to dazed and confused
where uh that guy you know that guy is
such a
interesting character but in other words
that line
tells you exactly who he is and makes
you want to do the movie think about it
you look at the line like that and you
go if this isn't a person's attitude if
this is a person's actual credo
ethos like he believes this you can
write a book
on somebody that goes about in the world
like that well in wolf of wall street
the launch pad line i remember reading
when i said who the [ __ ] is this guy and
he was t it was written that he tells
leonardo's character the secret to this
it's cocaine and hookers and i remember
going
who's this guy who that again he's seen
i was like if this guy's serious about
that
which i'm saying i'm going to take him
to be like he's being very serious boy i
can write a book on this guy so i just
started rapping
and and wrote things down and you know
was beating my chest before which was
leonardo's idea to put that actually in
the scene
and then i don't know it may have had
the stuff about jacking off and then i
added the stuff i don't know or maybe i
added that but i know i went on and
riffed on like oh whatever numbers yeah
those are rookie numbers those
those are working you got to pump those
up you know and then it was a
it was a wrap you know hey were you high
in dazed and confused or was that total
acting because i mean
it's total acting there's one scene in
there where uh uh
slater we were smoking oregano and
there's one scene in there
where slater um take take three
handed a real joint and it was actually
it was it was a great blessing because
it's the scene i don't even
know if you remember but it's one line
it was the only scene i was high in the
whole movie for actually
they jump the back of my car and worse
and goes well watch the leather man
you were high for that yeah
later it handed the prop joint and made
it a real joint on that take
and thankfully he did because one of my
favorite lines came out of my mouth
you